ولو تلخص لنا اخر المواقف منذ لحظه
الاغتيال في الواقع سلمى قبل دقيقتين صدر
بيان عن حزب الله حول اغتيال صالح
العاروري وسته من رفاقه في لبنان وجاء فيه
بان هذه الجريمه وفق توصيف حزب الله لن
تمر ابدا من دون عقاب والمقاومه على عهدها
ثابته والتزامها على نفسها ويدها على
الزناد وان المقاومه ستقوم بالرد وهي على
اقصى درجات
ان حزب الله يده على الزناد وفق توصيف
البيان الاخير الذي صدر قبل قليل وبالتالي
يمكن الحديث الان عن موقف اولي من حزب
الله يرتبط بعمليه اغتيال صالح العاروري
ورفاقه بالاضافه الى مجموعه من المواقف
الرسميه اللبنانيه التي سناتي على ذكرها
ولكن بالنسبه لموقف الحزب الذي صدر من
خلال هذا البيان كان الجميع يترقب امرين
الاول بيان واضح ورسمي من الحزب وايضا ما
سيي على ذكره الامين العام لحزب الله في
المؤتمر الصحفي او في الكلمه التي
سيواجهها يوم غد في الساعه السادسه
بالتوقيت المحلي هذا مستوى الذي يتعلق
بحزب الله وكيفيه تعامله مع هذا الاستهداف
في عمق الضاحيه الجنوبيه للبنان وكيفيه
الرد المحتمل وفق هذا البيان الصادر قبل
قليل على المستوى الرسمي اللبناني لابد من
الاشاره سلمى الى ما يتعلق بالموقف الصادر
عن رئاسه الحكومه اللبنانيه الذي ال كان
واضحا في تحميل اسرائيل المسؤوليه بشكل
مباشر معتبرا بان ما تقوم به اسرائيل او
ما قامت به اسرائيل من خلال عمليه
الاغتيال هذه انما هو محاوله لتصدير ازمه
نتنياهو من غزه باتجاه لبنان وفق توصيف
رئيس حكومه تصريف الاعمال وبالتالي هو
اشار الى ان كل هذه العمليه التي تم
تنفيذها من قبل اسرائيل تسعى الى ادخال
لبنان في مرحله جديده وان على المجتمع
الدولي ان يتدخل بشكل عاجل فيما يتعلق
بتطبيق القرارات الدوليه محملا اسرائيل
المسؤوليه الكامله عن خرق هذه القرارات لا
سما القرار
1701 وبالتالي سلمى هنا من خلال تقاطع هذه
البيانات سواء ما صدر عن حزب الله الان من
تحميل اسرائيل المسؤوليه بشكل مباشر
وتوعدها بالعقاب او من خلال البيان الصاد
عن رئاسه الحكومه ودعوه وزاره الخارجيه
الى تقديم الشكوى عاجله الى مجلس الامن
الدولي يمكن القول ان الموق المقف الرسمي
اللبناني والموقف الحزبي المرتبط بحزب
الله بطبيعه الحال يتقاطعان عند هذه
النقطه تحميل اسرائيل المسؤوليه واعتبار
بان ما عملت عليه اسرائيل من خلال عمليه
الاغتيال هذه انما يسعى الى نقل المواجهه
في جنوب لبنان الى مرحله اخرى والى مربع
اخر هذا هو التوصيف الذي تم استخدامه من
قبل الحزب ومن قبل رئيس حكومه تصيف
الاعمال ومن هنا يمكن الحديث عن ترقب
وخشيه في لبنان على مستوى ما ستحمله
الايام المقبله وكيفيه التعامل مع هذا
الامر لا سما ان ثمه من يقرا في لبنان بان
هذه العمليه والتنفيذ بهذه الطريقه من قبل
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من خلال اغتيال
قيادي على مستوى عال في حركه حماس
والاستهداف في عمق الضاحيه الجنوبيه انما
يرى وان البعض يرى هنا في لبنان بان هذا
الاستهداف هو دافعه جر ال الجبهه الجنوبيه
للبنان الى الى مربع اخر الى مواجهه
مفتوحه ومن هنا التساؤلات متعدده متشعبه
ولربما لخصها رئيس حكومه تصييف الاعمال من
خلال دعوتها المجتمع الدولي الى تدخل عاجل
على قاعده بان اسرائيل قامت بخلق كافه
القرارات الدوليه واليوم من خلال عمليه
الاغتيال هذه انما تخرق مجددا السياده
اللبنانيه وهذا عمليا هو رد يتقاطع بين
رئاسه الحكومه وايضا حزب الله الى كل من
يدعو لبنان لتطبيق الق قر 1701 بمعنى سحب
قوات حزب الله الى شمال نهر الليطاني
الكلام كان واضحا من رئيس الحكومه عندما
اعتبر بان من يخرق هذا القرار الدولي على
مستوى الجبهه الجنوبيه هو هي اسرائيل
وايضا من خلال هذا الاستهداف التي الذي
شهدناه اليوم عبر هذا الاغتيال الموجه
بالصواريخ في عمق ضاحيه بيروت الجنوبيه
وبالتالي سلمى كل هذه المعطيات تتقاطع عند
مجموعه من الاعتبارات التي ينظر لبنان
اليها سواء على المستوى الرسمي او الشعبي
او حتى على مستوى حزب الله الى ان الايام
المقبله ستكون حبله بتطورات معينه ينبغي
ان نراقبها بدقه لا سما ان المواقف التي
صدرت واخرها هذا البيان عن حزب الله يشير
الى ان هذا الاستهداف هو جريمه اسرائيليه
ووفق التوصيف الذي استخدمه حزب الله ووفق
المفردات التي استخدمها من خلال البيان هو
يتحدث عن عقاب وايضا يتحدث عن ان المقاومه
ي على الزناد مجددا وفق التعبيرات
والمفردات التي تم استخدامها من قبل حزب
الله وبالتالي ما كنا نشهده عند طول خط
هذه الجبهه لربما اليوم الجميع يترقب
يترقب اولا الموقف الذي سيضعه الامين
العام لحزب الله يوم غد هو امام تحد كبير
امام امتحان اكبر لان الامتحان يرتبط بان
الخطوط الحمراء التي كان قد رسم حزب الله
في المرحله السابقه فيما يتعلق
بالاغتيالات اذا ما نفذت على الاراضي
اللبنانيه وهو ما كان قد تحدث عنه الامين
العام لحزب الله هو وضع خطوطا حمراء من
هنا ثمه من يراقب التحدي الكبير الذي يمر
به لبنان من جهه والامتحان ايضا الذي يمر
به حزب الله ومن هنا مجموعه من المواقف
السياسيه المندده في لبنان والتي صدرت
تباعا من مجموعه كبيره من السياسيين في
مختلف المواقع والمواقف وهي تتقاطع عند
ادانه هذه الجريمه الاسرائيليه وفق
توصيفهم من خلال اغتيال العاروري و في
المقابل هنالك التوجس والترقب من كيفيه
تطور الامور خلال الساعات والايام المقبله
على مستوى الواقع اللبناني وتحديدا هنا في
جنوب لبنان نعم